but first we go to myanmar after decades
of isolation the country is experiencing
a new beginning
artists and intellectuals are welcoming
international exchange some with german
support
it has golden pagodas
and mineral resources
yet myanmar is one of the world's
poorest countries
for half a century the country was
isolated by its military dictatorship
but since 2011 the government of
president tane has cautiously opened up
in february 2014 german president
joachim garc reopened the goethe
institute
ten months later the villa once the
headquarters of the independence
movement is still a quiet place
institute founder franz salva augustine
and his colleagues have learned to be
patient when they encounter new
obstacles
colonial rule left this country
humiliated and that has led to the
people here treating everything that
comes from outside with a great
and it's a great challenge for us to
explain to people here that this
exchange
and this opening up and getting to know
others
will benefit them
this is
the white house
the goethe institute was closed for 50
years
but now augustine is doing everything he
can to rebuild ties between germany and
myanmar
this requires a lot of sensitivity
myanmar has been flooded by foreign
investment
the capital yangon with its 5 million
people feels like a boom town for the
first time
but after decades of isolation the
country is torn between those who
welcome these developments and those
worried by the rapid changes around them
the panzerdan gallery is a popular
meeting place for intellectuals its
founder is the publisher and collector
aung sumin
most of the bombings are just trying to
be to get more exposure and also like to
get more we connected and this is also
one is very important and the other
thing in my mind is myself it's what i'm
thinking it's like
i also
thinking to support and trying to open a
lot of the
small museums or big museums or whatever
in burma we also speak a lot about that
and also with the
many different kind of organization but
like i think guardian institute is very
important for that kind of knowledge
to make his dream of a museum a reality
aung swing collects everything he can
items that were kept out of public view
for decades like photographs posters and
old magazines from the 1950s
augustine is a regular visitor and each
time he comes aung sumin has new
treasures to display
this time he has an old advertising
poster for an east german fashion show
in yangon
that was in 1961 at the time west
germany still had a goethe institute
here
in the early days there was a flowering
of german burmese relations east and
west germany competed with each other to
win favor in myanmar
such as
after the military coup in 1962 the
ghetto institute was forced to close
today people here have new educational
and cultural opportunities
the independent art and gallery scene
hopes to establish itself in warehouses
in the harbour district
wanu and her husband tunwan aung have
taken part in international exhibitions
like at the new york guggenheim but they
were almost unknown in their own country
until recently
i have the feeling that my international
exhibitions have helped a lot to make me
better known in my own country
that was really the biggest problem so
far i couldn't exhibit in myanmar but
slowly the audience here has become
interested in my art
wanu comes from a family of artists
her father muang wuno was one of the
country's top film directors in the
1970s
but most of his works disappeared during
the military dictatorship
wanu has made it her mission to save his
movies
his film tender are the feet was
restored with goethe institute help
its international premiere was at the
2014 berlin film festival
the film tells the story of a young
singer who decides to become a film star
against the will of her boyfriend and
who prefers the western lifestyle to the
traditional burmese one
my father was often visited by the
centers when he was editing the film
scenes were shortened and some
disappeared completely such as scenes of
the western style nightlife in yangon
i'm very happy that this film is now
screening at festivals in the restored
version
it's what my father always hoped for
cinemas and the capital yangon still
mostly screen european films and
american blockbusters but the local film
scene is finding its feet again
movie and video making they also start
again of the censorship so in some way
one is like this never been clear
someone can be censored for many
different reasons so this is also like a
i think it's a noun is
some progress so a lot of people can
expect in some different way but at the
same time it's not clear yet
and it's also not clear who will be in
charge in myanmar in the future
the country is in a very fragile state
myanmar's first free elections will be
held in march
many in the west pin their hopes on
opposition leader aung san tsuchi
but people here are looking to the
elections with mixed feelings
some demand a return to traditions while
others desire modernity
but most want one thing above all
and that is stability
you